the Joe Rogan experience let's bring it
home it's bringing home an A+ thing bro
that's the fight no it's talking about
you want a rose hey Jamie tell uh
homeboys gonna watch the monitor um yeah
Doug Rose no it's not it's being
overshadowed yeah it is being
overshadowed it's a crazy one right it's
because you nobody expected it to go
down the way it did in the first one you
know not at all and the rematch you on
is on wait she's way lighter
she was 122 last week you know so she's
just a few pounds away here's my problem
with this fight and I'm I'm actually I
might stop making picks I said on the
podcast it doesn't make me feel good
when I pick against people it doesn't
make me feel good I feel like I have to
do it a lot of people don't do picks and
they come to me for pigs what do you
think's gonna happen for a long time I
thought oof Rose rose she's a monster
and I know Rose right from Denver she'll
and that left hook and Trevor teaches
that and Pat Barry teaches that and
that's exactly one to do amazing fight I
bet they fight you know three or four
times but if they do a rematch which
they should give you on the meet at
rematch roses me a little bit of trouble
cuz you on is a [ __ ] machine here's
the caveat to that when I see you on a
do interviews and she goes it was my
nutritionist it was this person it was
this it was this she never once says she
take owned it and taking credibility oh
that's not the way a world champion
speaks that's not the way at all someone
talks yeah and when I see a bunch of
excuse I go oh [ __ ] you have a hole in
your boat and you're cut you're masking
it with duct tape and you're trying to
get back to this point mm you just math
you're not solved you're not actually
patching that up and so you're
susceptible again and now you you're
talking like that never happened it was
a fluke
Rose is pretty [ __ ] good and if you
don't respect her again you think it's
your nutritionist is why you lost that
fight you're probably gonna lose again
you might be right
you might be wrestling i bothers me I
think you honest when the greatest
change is all time when the greatest
fighters but it's just when I see that
like oh you're just gonna you're going
about the wrong way and she goes you
know I even talked to Rhonda and you
know she said she had a weight cut like
no one's dealt with losses worse than
Rhonda you don't want to preface that
you don't want to reference that at all
right I don't want to see that out of
Jana she has so much more work to do
yeah well it's all so you wanna had a
long career in Muay Thai a long career
you know like a lot of fights yeah done
a lot of kickboxing sparring a lot of
MMA sparring sometimes your chin just
goes I mean this is a there's a real
possibility sometimes you shouldn't just
go you think it's a chin thing to I
don't know yeah I don't know I think
it's too early to call for that
especially at that weight class I think
for her it's more she just wasn't being
respectful of rows I thought she's gonna
walk through and all the [ __ ] talked and
she was doing right and Rose is a
different animal she she reminds me of
Brian are taking a little bit where
where she's very dangerous on on
conventional and the certain spot she
can't train for so I she's that type of
animal with similar Brian Artega but
with Johanna if the gun to my head I'll
tell you on a wins by decision mmm
but again I hate making picks makes me
feel badly yeah making picks is tough
man because you you know you're gonna
piss people off and you know they're
over [ __ ] against me no that's no no
no you have to look at the analysis of
it before the fight I thought Rose was
in trouble I'm like Johannes very hard
to take down to her stand-up is world
class and I think she's she could very
well pick Rose apart and you know and
and cracker I she's coming in but when
she hit her with that left she hit her
before that and hurt her but when she
hit her with that left hook I was like
gee explosive - she looks good man and
Rose like on the embedded Rose was Pat
Barry takes a giant box of tennis balls
and throws tennis balls at her and she's
popping tennis balls in the air and she
looks [ __ ] solid and rose to her
ceiling is we're just seeing it it's
just so much room for girl she's so
young just Pat just Trevor around her
and now forever people like you're gonna
be world champion and when everyone
tells coaches tell fighters all the time
but when actually happen you go oh [ __ ]
yeah they're not bullshitting they're
not just saying this and I think it when
you said she believes it now you're
dealing with different thug rows you're
dealing with different Johanna Johanna
doesn't think she's the greatest gift to
the MMA world so that kind of
combination such a fascinating fight and
no one's talking about it yeah
everyone is so caught up in this
cancellation and the Ferguson cabbie
fight was so huge for the heart cords
for sure but it's also one of those
things where with Rose coming into this
fight now and you want to make an
excuses for the last fight you know I'm
really interested to see like what
happens when they square off
I can't wait for left on each other is
Jana gonna do the same talk to him again
and Rosie's reciting the Bible I don't
think she can I don't think I don't
think you wanna can do the same talking
you know you don't think she goes this
was a fluke I'm doing the exact same
thing no I think Rose gonna stare right
through her [ __ ] soul like I'm the
champion when you talk a gang of [ __ ] at
someone and they just stare right
through you and then they murk you in
the first round it's very tough the
second time it's gonna be interesting I
think that's a sign if you want it isn't
respecting Rose again if she gets up
there and start talking that [ __ ] I
would put a ton of money on Rose yeah
yeah if I see her doing the same things
oh [ __ ] you learn nothing girl nothing
well it's whether or not Rose can
clipper again if Rose charges in and
clips or again it's also the thing about
a striker always worried about being
taken down is more likely to get hit
with a shot yeah like Kevin Randleman
when he knocked out Mirko Cro Cop
correct
same thing like Kevin was the threat as
a wrestler leaps in with a left hook and
catches him right on a chin knocks him
the [ __ ] out I think there's a there's a
real correlation there I wouldn't be
surprised if you want to so focus on
improving her stand-up and you know it's
like I get caught this time just gonna
overwhelm her stand up she gets
submitted she overlooked the submission
game of Rose which is actually Rose's
best weapon that's what I was thinking I
was thinking bro tweets we might see
Rose threw a flying arm correct you
might see Rose different wild [ __ ]
doesn't care about be on her back no no
and she's fast
she she goes for [ __ ] she like she's a
wild explosive person you know and she's
a really interesting thinker too you
know she had a tough life man yeah tough
life grow and develop this very strong
mind because controlled chaos is what I
got she's brilliant yeah
[Applause]